bon ajoutons que près de 5000 personnes
ont sablé le champagne et croquer des
petits fours aujourd'hui dans les
jardins de l'élysée admirateurs célèbres
ou inconnues ils ont tous tenté
d'approcher le président pour le saluer
ou tout simplement pour le voit michel
vial
tradition respectée une fois encore à
l'elysée la république avait ouvert les
portes du premier de ces palais à
quelques-uns de ses citoyens de toute
façon des privilégiés en le refrain dans
la bousculade la plus chic de l'année un
exceptionnel bien qu'artificielle moment
de grâce pendant quelques heures en
effet des français anonymes et modestes
se sont égayés parmi les ors et les
oripeaux du pouvoir
un peu intimidés par eux en même temps
que satisfait d'être reçu dans ce qu il
considère néanmoins comme leur maison
commune
ils ont donc approcher et côtoyer mais
les ont-ils vraiment rencontré le tout
étalé représentants de la nomenklatura
et de l'intelligentsia
d'où ce contraste saisissant entre de
france très différentes que seul au fond
la commémoration de la révolution
française fin de réunir sous les lambris
fastueux et austère de l'elysée une
ambiguïté souriante et pittoresques dont
se remettra aisément la république
jusqu'à l'année prochaine tout comme le
parc de l'elysée rendue en milieu
d'après-midi à sa majestueuse
tranquillité
là